carry fresh vegetables and fruits around
the city and horse-drawn carts
my grandfather's been doing it all his
life he 80-something years old now
i've been doing it all my life and it's
been around
50 maybe 100 years before me
in baltimore you got markets around but
you got to have a vehicle to get to them
it's going to cost them to get there
cause them to get back so it's
beneficial to a lot of people for the
rappers to be on the streets
y'all have a go
every morning pull my wagon out i get
all the fruit together and design it up
make it look nice
and then i take the horse and put them
in the wagon i start on my day
you mostly call out what you got on your
wagon
when you come up and you see an elderly
person just waiting at the door for you
to come through and they give you their
little list that's a wonderful feeling
they depend on us and we try to be there
for them
a rabbit's for life baby a rabbit's for
life
the kids they love the horse
and i want them to be able to see that
selling drugs ain't the only way to make
money
this is what keeps me out of trouble
this is what feed my families will put
food on the table pay the bills pay the
gas
this is one of the oldest things in in
the city that's still going right now
this is history
when i was a little kid it was nothing
for me to turn the corner and see a
rapper one right behind another
sometimes
we don't get a lot of people behind us
in the exposed arabian business it might
eventually die out
but my dream is to see it last forever
till the day i shut my eyes for good
you